is this the new normal
facing the uk a climate warning that is
now
all too real from severe flooding
to more extreme heat unusual for these
aisles
a pattern the country is struggling to
cope with
it's the shift in the baseline what we
regard as normal weather
that is changing and we see a lot of
these examples in our data for example
34 degrees celsius recorded in seven of
the last 10 years
um but the 50 years before that it was
seven times in the previous 50 years
before that so something that was
relatively unusual
is becoming much more common since the
start of the last century the sea levels
have already doubled from 1.5 to more
than 3
millimeters a year and in the past 30
years alone
not only has the uk warmed by 0.9
degrees celsius
it has also become six percent wetter
on paper that may seem a small
difference
in reality this is the effect
the infrastructure is simply unable to
cope
and there is no quick fix in sight in
the face of the elements
sea level will not be possible to
reverse on any short time scale
there is a commitment to sea level rise
that has started
which will persist over many many
hundreds of years even if we stopped all
co2 emissions today
it is part of a wider phenomenon of
extreme weather across the continent
recent floods in western europe have
wreaked devastation
and rivers in germany surged to levels
not seen in
hundreds of years the the predictions of
of are very clear that with essentially
more
heat energy in the system and the
atmosphere able to hold more water
um that we are likely to get more
storminess more extreme events
wetter events becoming wetter drier
events becoming drier
and the predictions around sea level uh
it's an inexorable rise that are
are clear the race is on to find a
solution as quickly as possible
the uk and italy will host the cop 26
climate change conference
in glasgow later this year set against a
climate crisis that has seen all manner
of extreme events around the world
the uk calls the summit the world's last
best chance
to repair the damage caused by increased
carbon emissions
but there is little detail as of yet on
what plans the world's 20 major
economies have
to prevent a further increase in
dangerously
extreme weather conditions sony gallego
al jazeera